[Musique]
France Allemagne un couple en thérapie
signé Olivier Tosser et Jean-Marie
magraau un film dont le diagnostic est
peut-être un peu inquiétant Berlin et
Paris sont-elles en train de se séparer
oui non pourquoi quelles conséquence
avec nous pour en parler ronand legleu
bienvenue à vous vous êtes sénateur LR
représentant les Français établis hors
de France membre de la commission des
Affaires étrangères et européennes
président du groupe interparlementaire
d'amitié France- Allemagne au Sénat et
je précise que vous êtes né en Allemagne
et que vous y vivez en tout cas une
bonne partie de l'année Jean-Marc herud
bienvenue à vous merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation ancien Premier ministre
ancien ministre des Affaires étrangères
aujourd'hui président de la Fondation
pour la mémoire de l'esclavage grand
germanophile et plusieurs fois salué
pour avoir Ré au rapprochement entre la
France et l'Allemagne Michael viigel
bienvenue à vous également vous êtes
journaliste correspondante à Paris de la
F7 Frankfurter algemet saitung l'un des
deux quotidiens allemands les plus lus
outrerin et je précise également que
vous avez publié un livre Macron
l'Européen en 2018 Marion gaillard
bienvenue à vous également vous êtes
enseignante docteur en histoire
spécialiste des relations
franco-allemandes et des questions
européennes et vous avez publié l'Union
européenne institution et politique à la
Documentation française merci beaucoup à
tous les quatre d'être avec nous
aujourd'hui avant d'entrer dans le
détail je voudrais votre diagnostic à
vous essayons si possible d'ailleurs de
filer la métaphore du couple he qui est
très utilisé dans le documentaire le
couple franco-allemand est-il en
souffrance voir en instance de orce
ronand lebleleu la situation est
complexe c'est une évidence mais de
toute façon un Français et Allemand même
s'ils ne s'aiment pas en filant la
métaphore de toute façon n'ont pas le
choix il n ils n'ont pas le choix ils ne
peuvent pas divorcer on le voit parce
que tout simplement qui aujourd'hui
toque à la porte du G20 personne alors
que les bricks on le voit bien à partir
du 1er janvier à venir vont accueillir
six nouveaux membres l'Iran l'Arabie
Saoud les Émirats arabes unis l'Éthiopie
l'Égypte l'Argentine vont s'ajouter au
brixs actuels alors que
personne-o donc Brésil Russie Inde Chine
et Afrique du Sud vont accueillir six
nouveaux pays au 1er janvier dans le
club du Brix et on le voit bien que ce
soit le G7 ou le G20 aujourd'hui on ne
toque plus à la porte de ces pays pour
les rejoindre c'est donc finalement une
question géopolitique fondamentale de la
place de l'Occident
dans les équilibres mondiaux et français
et allemands n'ont pas le choix de
s'entendre même si parfois le cœur n'y
est pas ou le cœur n'y est plus est-ce
que c'est parfois ou est-ce que c'est
profond quand même elle est là la
question la situation est d'autant plus
complexe que nous nous éloignons du 8
Mai 45 c'est-à-dire que ce qui était le
foul du moteur franco-allemand comme le
disent les Allemands les allemands
parlent plutôt du moteur franco-allemand
plutôt que de couple il faut pas y voir
nous Français comme un manque de
d'affection pour cette relation
franco-allemande les Allemands sont le
c'est c'est le pays leader mondial de
l'automobile alors quand eu parle de
moteur franco-allemand c'est une vertu
positive il faut pas faire une erreur
d'interprétation ils mettent moins
d'affect que nous peut-être Jean-Marc
herud comment vous la voyez cette
relation franco-alement aujourdhui je
pense que quand on regarde d'ailleurs
dans le documentaire on a quelques
extraits de relations au niveau des
sociétés civiles et c'est très
intéressant parce que les les Français
les Allemands s'apprécient au-delà des
politiques au-delà des gouvernements
vous parlez des peuples là oui oui oui
ça c'est très important parce que ça
s'est construit au fil du temps après
les années 50 hein les Français les
Allemands avaient peu de relations même
des très mauvaises relations avit
beaucoup de préjugés de de de de
ressentiment aussi mais la le tournant
c'est quand même ce geste français le 9
mai 1950 cette déclaration de Robert
Schuman ministre des Affaires étrangères
et qui va ouvrir en quelqu quelque sorte
le début de la relation franco-allemande
et la construction européenne c'est un
c'est une main tendue à l'Allemagne et
donc c'est le premier acte de
réconciliation et c'est un acte
politique fondateur alors on vit avec
cet héritage les présidents successifs
les grandes initiatives le traité
francoalemand son renouvellement tout ça
ça existe alors après au
quotidien il faut d'abord il faut pas
oublier que chaque pays a son sa propre
vie politique et son autonomie et vie
voilà non seulement souverain mais parce
que bon tous les jours nous ne parlons
pas de la relation franco-allemande hein
chacun vit dans son contexte
démocratique national et donc sur
certaines questions importantes il y a
des désaccords qui subsistent voir euh
sur lesquels n'arrivons pas à trouver de
solution on va peut-être y revenir mais
fondamentalement même avec
l'élargissement euh de l'Europe et qui
va se développer la relation
franco-allemande à mon avis durera mais
il faut la re refonder en permanence la
revivifier la consolider comme un couple
si on continue de filer cette M j'aime
bien aussi les le le l'idée de moteur m
parce que ce qui me frappe c'est que
beaucoup de pays sont irrités par cette
relation un peu spécial on dire
privilégié entre l'Allemagne et la
France et en même tempsal jaloux c'est
pas ça mais on n pas envie que vous
décidiez à notre place on peut pas être
mis devant le fait accompli on le voit
bien de grands partenaires et de plus
petits partenaires qui parfois s'en
irrit puis en même temps quand la
relation franco-allemande ne fonctionne
pas bien que les décisions pour
continuer à à à à à développer l'Europe
sont pas prises on on reproche au au
moteurs franco-allemand ou au couple
franco-allemand de pas avoir fait son
travail michikel avgal il B de l'aile ce
couple quand même alors je vais
reprendre la métaphore du couple même en
étant allemande parce que je crois ce
qu'on vit aujourd'hui c'est qu'il y en a
un dans le couple qui change beaucoup et
l'autre qui reste un peu dans ses
convictions dont on s'arrive assez
souvent dans les
relations venir lequel reste dans ses
convictions alors devinez celui qui a le
plus changé c'est l'Allemagne
l'Allemagne a objectivement changé avec
la réunification mais ça a mis aussi un
certain temps d'arriver dans les têtes
et deuxièmement l'Allemagne est rattrapé
l'Allemagne s'est construit sur le
pacifisme sur le plus jamais de la
guerre et est rattrapé par une situation
mondiale qui euh tempant à l'éloigner
énormément de la France parce que nous
n'avons pas l'arme nucléaire on en parle
dans dans dans le documentaire nous nous
avons aussi euh euh un sentiment de
vulnérabilité qui beaucoup plus forte je
crois que qu'en France et je crois du
coup on a la réaction de quelqu'un qui
s'occupe beaucoup de lui-même et qui dit
mais euh toi avec tes certitudes euh tu
tu crois que tu peux me dire ce que je
dois faire mais moi je suis dans une
situation nouvelle j'ai je dois gérer
tout ce qui a changé chez moi et ce qui
change autour vous nous dites que la
France ne ne suit pas cette évolution
qu'elle observe en Allemagne voire ne la
voit pas ne l'observe pas d'ailleurs
elle pas à l'écoute de ce que la France
est resté dans ses convictions c'est
tout à son honneur aussi hein dans ses
convictions avant de guerre de l'Ukraine
je parle bien sûr c'est-à-dire la
l'autonomie stratégique la souveraineté
européenne alors qu'en Allemagne il y a
une prise de conscience que sonans les
États-Unis euh on est perdu pour le dire
de façon un peu eu un peu exagéré mais
ça pour conséquence que le chancelier
schz au lieu de de chercher l'alliance
avec la France cherche l'alliance avec
le président américain on y viendra à
cette question de la guerre en Ukraine
qui a évidemment été un tournant hein
dans la relation dans ce couple
franco-allemand mais je voudrais encore
continuer d'échanger sur ce constat qui
est fait et qui est très fort dans le
documentaire sur ce couple qui irait
vraiment très mal euh on a même Bruno Le
Maire dans le film qui nous parle de
mariage forcé plutôt que de mariage
d'amour ce qui supposerait qu'il y a
presque un visce de forme au départ
Marion gaillard alors je vais continuer
effectivement à filer cette métaphore
parce que j'aime bien cette métaphore
que je trouve assez juste plus qu'un
mariage forcé je dirais un mariage de
raison c'est dit aussi et ça revient à
ce qui a été déjà dit là en plateau
c'est-à-dire que c'est pas un mariage
d'amour et en 1950 quand Robert Schuman
fait le geste du 9 mai c'est pas par
amour pour l'Allemagne c'est par
nécessité effectivement et parce qu'on a
bien compris is que on ne peut plus
comme en
1918-19 écraser l'Allemagne que il ne
faut pas retomber comme dit jean-monet
dans les ornières du passé et donc il
faut tenter autre chose et tenter autre
chose c'est accepter alors on tente
autre chose pas complètement
volontairement c'est parce que les
Américains nous poussent à
réindustrialiser l'Allemagne dans le
contexte de la guerre froide et de la
menace soviétique nous on n' pas très
envie de réindustrialiser l'Allemagne
mais on n' pas tellement le choix et
donc on on s'en sort par le haut cette
fois en propos posant cette communauté
du charbon et de l'acier mais comme
c'était très bien dit par jean-marqu
herot c'est une réconciliation des
gouvernements et il faut ensuite
réconcilier les peuple c'est ce que vise
à faire le traité de l'Élysée avec
notamment la création de l'Office
franco-allemand de la jeunesse donc il y
a bien cette idée de sceller la
réconciliation à travers les peuples ça
c'est très très important c'est
intéressant que vous distinguiez le côté
politique du côté population parce que
il y a un intervenant qui disait dans
dans ce film que les Allemands se
demandaient à un moment donné si ça
valait encore la peine de faire
apprendre le français à leurs enfants
alors que c'est la Chine qui domine
c'est peut-être anecdotique mais moi ça
m'a semblé assez symbolique côté
français les cours d'Allemands se vide
aussi qu'est-ce que ça veut dire en 1994
610000 élèves choisissaient l'allemand
comme première langue en 2021 ils
étaient seulement 150000 qu'est-ce que
ça dit de l'amitié entre nos peuples
cette fois Renant Leleu ça dit aussi que
la mondialisation est mondiale c'est un
euphémisme mais ça veut dire aussi que
pour les français quand ils partent
tenter la aventure à l'étranger il tente
aussi l'aventure au bout du monde et pas
simplement chez le Pr proche voisin qui
signifie une proximité géographique en
réalité aujourd'hui on tente l'aventure
et il y a de plus en plus de nos
compatriotes qui tentent l'aventure à
l'étranger c'est ça la vraie raison
c'est une des raisons c'est-à-dire que
aujourd'hui le monde est un horizon et
donc on on ose aller sur d'autres
continents beaucoup plus que par le
passé on le voit ne serait-ce que sur le
nombre de nos compatriotes est intact et
C cours d'Allemands qui se vident c'est
cette question de la langue allemande
qui qui est beaucoup moins répandue
aujourd'hui parmi nos élèves ne dit rien
de de l'amitié des peuples l'inimitié
des peuples je pense quand même ça ça
dit long sur un manque de
curiosité qui malheureusement s'est
répandu dans la nouvelle génération dans
les nouvelles générations c'est-à-dire
on prend la paix pour quelque chose de
garanti ça c'est bien c'est vrai c'est
un acquis c'était pas quelque chose et
je crois que malheure
heureusement les gouvernements font peu
pour pour en quelque
sorte entretenir le lien entretenir le
lien mais surtout en cité là on a la
décision du gouvernement allemand de
fermer les les instituts culturels les
gout dans les dans les villes où pour
moi on aurait le plus pour simple raison
financière et parce que on dit que notre
nouvelle stratégie c'est de se tourner
vers l'est et vers l'Asie donc on
sacrifie l'Institut de Bordeaux de
lillele qui sont parmi les les les plus
huvieuxes institut et Strasbourg et
Strasbourg ça dit quelque chose et ça
dit quelque chose et Toulouse par
exemple c'est quand même la ville
d'erbus je veux pas décrire un tableau
trop noir mais ça m'inquiète beaucoup la
ville d'erbus l'Institut Culturel n'a
déjà plus de section pour apprendre la
langue donc fait plus des cours et le le
la partie cult c'està-dire pour attirer
l'intérêt n'a plus qu'un budget annuel
de 5000 € qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
avec ça pas
grandchoseall oui moi je vis je vis ça
avec beaucoup de de tristesse de voir le
nombre d'élèves français qui qui
apprennent l'allemand en diminution et
en même temps pour le français en
Allemagne je trouve que c'est tout à
fait regrettable et il faut une volonté
politique pour pour résoudre cette
question ça suffit pas mais si on se dés
gage si on considère si on ne prend pas
en compte le fait que la dimension
culturelle euh ne fait pas partie d'une
relation entre les peuples alors il y a
quelque chose qu'on comprend pas c'est
une approche totalement utilitariste
budgétaire et qui me paraît être une
faute politique parce que l'Europe est
constitué de différentes nations de
différentes langues de différentes
cultures de différentes histoires même
si nous avons énormément de choses en
commun mais nous avons besoin de
comprendre l'autre dans la relation
franco-allemande moi ça m'a beaucoup
toujours beaucoup frappé euh alors parce
que j'ai un intérêt pour la langue
allemande que le fait de de la de la
pratiquer rendait la relation avec
l'autres en particulier moi me
concernant avec des Allemands beaucoup
plus profonde et parce que je
j'acceptais de rentrer dans dans la la
la pensée de l'autre de ce de comment il
raisonne comment il comment il
fonctionne et les questions auxquelles
il est lui-même confronté et vous aviez
raison de de de de de parler du désarroi
allemand et de l'angoisse allemande
concernant sa propre sécurité que la
facilité c'est de retourner à nouveau
vers les États-Unis alors que les
États-Unis ne sont peut-être pas une
solution durable parce que c'est ça qui
est un risque politique important
notamment pour l'Allemagne dont je
comprends à quelques kilomètres de la
frontière polonaise que il y a une vraie
question de sécurité et que le discours
de Scholz du chancelier Scholz sur le
tiit and
vender le changement d'air et qui dans
lequel il annonce qu'il va investir dans
la défense effectivement vous avez
parfaitement raison nous on le vit
positivement en France parce qu'on est
conscient que un jour ou l'autre
peut-être qu'on sera tout seul pour
assurer notre propre défense si par
exemple monsieur Trump était élu
président des États-Unis à une deuxième
fois je ne suis pas sûr que le soutien à
l'Ukraine continuerait je ne suis pas
sûr qu'il se désengrègerait pas de la
sécurité en Europe donc la question
fondamentale dans la relation
franco-allemande que nous avons toujours
devant nous comment
consodilt-on le projet européen et et et
dans les fêtes même si on parle de crise
dans la relation entre nos deux pays ça
marche pas si mal que ça parce qu'au
moment du covid on va y venir au moment
du covid au moment de de la crise
économique qui qui a qui a suivi il y a
bien eu un accord franco-allemand et
donc vous parliez de la réunification
ben moi je me souviens de la colère de
François miteran reprochement à elmouco
au moment de la de la de la de la de la
fin de la Yougoslavie lorsque
l'Allemagne reconnaît la Croatie miteran
était très en colère et il a eu des
explications avec Almou Cole mais quand
il il a fallu euh comment dire
arrivriver à une une conclusion
concernant la réunification à notamment
dans la relation avec la Pologne la la
reconnaissance de la frontière
euh ben il y a un accord qui est passé
miteran et col se sont mis d'accord et
c'était un accord historique et c'est
pas venu du jour au lendemain donc les
tensions c'est parfois préoccupant mais
il faut pas en avoir peur à chaque fois
nous sommes dans une période un peu
compliqué mais je suis sûr qu'on finira
par par trouver des solutions et des
réponses parce que comme vous le dites à
juste titre c'est une nécessité Marion
gaillard oui c'est vrai que justement
François miteran disait à propos de ces
disputes autour de la réunification et
de la la guerre en ex-yugoslavie qui a
vraiment été un point de tension très
fort entre les deux on mesure la
solidité d'un couple à sa capacité à
répondre aux cris c'est parce qu'on est
différent parce qu'on part de positions
différentes au départ et qu'on a ses
outils pour créer un compromis qu'on
peut être un moteur pour l'Europe parce
que si on était d'accord dès l'origine
on créerait rien du tout pour l'Europe
on part de là on arrive à un compromis
qui est faisable pour les Européens
c'est le cas pour le covid dans un
couple en difficulté les torss sont
souvent partagés mais vous l'avez
peut-être ressenti le parti prix du film
c'est semble-t-il de dire que c'est
l'Allemagne qui fait souvent cavalier
seul sur la question du nucléaire sur la
question des réfugiés sur la question
des frontièr au moment du covid et puis
plus récemment sur le plan militaire
vous l'avez un petit peu évoqué on va y
venir en détail l'Allemagne a
effectivement commandé ses fameux 35
chasseurs bombardier F35 aux Américains
plutôt que d'acheter des rafales
français autant vous dire que la p a été
très difficile à avaler côté français
[Musique]
écoutez Allemagne a essayé de faire
comprendre à la France que l'achat de
ces 35 avions était une solution
transitoire directement liée à des
besoins militaires à savoir le
remplacement des Tornados des avions de
combat allemands CAPAES de transporter
des bombes nucléaires américaines
jusqu'à leur cible en cas
d'urgence ce qui serait formidable aussi
dans les avancé à venir euh c'est que
l'équipement militaire allemand soit un
équipement européen plutôt qu'un
équipement américain parce que je pense
que ça c'est la prochaine étape et c'est
une étape importante à
franchir Michel viguel cette décision a
été vraiment vécue comme un acte de
défiance côté français à tort selon vous
oui alors je pense malheureusement ça
euh remet un peu un question de la bonne
connaissance de l'autre pays euh parce
que en réalité je crois en France on a
oublié que
la France on a parlé de de la CA qui
était un moment fondateur mais il y
avait un autre moment fondateur qui n'a
pas eu lieu en
1954 quand on a voulu intégrer
l'Allemagne militairement dans la
Communauté européenne de défense et la
France c'était un 54 a dit non euh et du
coup l'Allemagne a été intégrée à l'OTAN
euh et a obtenu un peu plus tard le
partage nucléaire avec les États-Unis
c'est-à-dire les États-Unis se portent
depuis garant en cas de d'attaque vital
euh de pouvoir répondre avec des bombes
américaines et en France on a oublié ça
et je crois cette question du partage
nucléaire est clé pour comprendre
beaucoup de comportements parce que la
menace nucléaire de Vladimir Poutine a
été perçu de façon vraiment très très
menaçante euh en Allemagne le chancelier
lui-même a dit que il était enquier et
je crois que la France ne réalise pas
souvent come bien le fait d'être maître
de la disversion nucléaire protège les
Français de cette pensée et puis plus
généralement il y a une vraie différence
de perception de ce conflit entre la
Russie et l'Ukraine côté français et
côté allemand on le vit pas de la même
façon oui le vend effectivement de Olaf
Scholz c'est un retournement historique
absolument fondam dont il faut prendre
la mesure qui est née de la peur réelle
existentielle par l'Allemagne de la
Russie suite à l'invasion en Ukraine
sentiment que Paris n'a pas eu les
Français n'ont pas eu le sentiment de
peur d'une invasion russe encore une
fois je pense que c'est important de se
mettre dans la logique de l'autre sinon
on reste sur des a prioris et des
blocages vous navez pas compris que côté
français on se fâche de cette décision
j'ai compris que c'est plus pour
l'avenir qu' a pose une question se pose
la question dans le choix madame Begel a
très bien expliqué les choses et je
crois qu'il faut être juste et
reconnaître cette réalité là qui est
aussi une réalité historique et un fait
et ce qui explique cette relation
particulière avec les États-Unis pour la
sécurité mais pour laavenir
effectivement la question est posée
est-ce qu'il y aura un char
franco-allemand pour un programme qui a
été décidé ensemble et je suis pas
certain que ça soit le cas là c'est vrai
que la France a des raisons d'être déçu
la même chose pour l'avion du futur il y
avait deux programmes milita important
d'investissement et j'ai l'impression
que c'est soit reporté et donc si ça se
fait ça sera très très tardivement ou
alors même ça ça va être abandonné et ça
c'est vraiment dommage parce que là il y
a il y a un malentendu mais ce que nous
dit le film ça va au-delà de la question
militaire ce qu'on ressent une fois
qu'on a vu ce documentaire c'est que
l'Allemagne fait régulièrement cavalier
seul pas que sur les questions
militaires c'est un tort de le pens
parfo nous faire aussi le reproche de
décider tout seul vous savez c'est pas
si pas je pense qu'il faut pas s'envoyer
comme ça des à la figure des ce type
d'argument cavalier sol je l'ai vu dans
le documentaire c'est vrai mais
en je va dire quelque chose de positif
pour l'avenir de l'Europe là les deux
ministres délégués aux Affaires
européennes françaises et allemand ont
commandé à des experts des propositions
sur la réforme des institutions dans la
perspective de l'élargissement au
Balcans et peut-être même de l'Ukraine
et il y a eu une discussion sur cette
question entre entre le président Macron
et le chancelier Olaf Scholz notamment
sur l'élargissement jusqu'à présent la
France la position officielle de la
France c'est une position hostile à
l'élargissement au Balcans et le
président Macron a fait une ouverture et
le président le chanceiller des Choles
de son côté en a fait une autre aussi
élargissant d'un côté approfondissement
de l'autre et ça se traduit par cette
prop cette demande cette commande qui a
été faite à un certain nombre d'experts
franco-allemands de faire des
propositions de réforme institutionnelle
pour faire fonctionner l'Europe pour
demain et après-demain alors je ne sais
pas ce que les gouvernements retiendront
de ces propositions je suis aussi
président de la fondation jeanuress et
nous avions une réunion il y a quelques
jours pour présenter les propositions de
ces experts avec l'Institut Jacques del
lor et avec le grand continent et je
trouve que ces experts franco-allemands
ont bien travaillé ils mettent sur la
table un certain nombre de propositions
parce qu'on Nimagine pas un
élargissement de l'Europe à 35 peut-être
demain un peu plus sans qu'on réforme
nos institutions pour faire fonctionner
l'Europe ça veut dire qui a conscience
je pense même si la concrétisation peut
parfois laisser à désirer que l'Europe
est notre destin et notre avenir plus
que jamais mais est-ce que l'axe de
pouvoir ne se déplace pas vers l'est et
cela d'ailleurs depuis la ch mais c'est
une réalité il s'agit pas d'ignorer le
fait que la Pologne est aux frontières
de l'Europe et d'où la fragilisation de
ce donc parlons avec la avec la avec la
Pologne comm nous parlons avec l'Espagne
il faut considérer la Pologne comme un
grand pays alors moi je me réjouis du
résultat des élections en Pologne hein
ça va per m sans doute ce rapprochement
c'est une bonne chose mais est-ce que
avec cet élargissement vers l'Est avec
ce déplacement de l'axe de pouvoir
européen qui ne semble plus être
complètement centré sur le couple
franco-allemand c'est pas aussi le signe
que peut-être la France s'est illusionné
a cru à ce couple franco-allemand a
espéré quelque chose de ce couple
franco-allemand qui n'est plus vraiment
d'actualité aussi parce que peut-être la
France c'est on parle de déclassement de
la France peut-être qu'elle ne joue plus
dans la même cours que l'Allemagne
Marion parfois la France s'illusionne
sur l'ensemble de ses partenaires
européens intéressant pourquoi en terme
de défense nous sommes les seuls
véritablement à croire à l'autonomie
stratégique en réalité tous nos
partenaires européens sans exception
mise leur sécurité sur le bouclier
américain donc il y a un cvage profond
est seul à avoir l'arme atomique hein
c'est à part les les Britanniques
j'entends c'estàd qu'il faut quand même
bien moi je rejoins ce qui a été dit les
Allemands n'y ont pas droit ils y ont
renoncé et on leur a aussi demandé de
réaffirmer cette renonciation au moment
de la réunification allemande donc on ne
on ne peut pas réfléchir comme un
français sur cette situation sans
prendre en considération cette fragilité
intrinsèque qui est celle de l'Allemagne
donc dans ce cadre- là comment peut-on
réellement abandonner un bouclier
militaire américain au profit d'une
approximative défense européenne donc
c'est c'est la poule et l'uf vous allez
me dire le problème c'est que je suis
d'accord il faut arriver à se mettre
dans la peau de l'autre ce que peut-être
on n'arrive pas toujours à faire d'un
côté comme de l'autre d'ailleurs et on
le fait d'autant mieux qu'on se conna
bien et et donc il y a certaines
relations qui fonction n'empêche que il
faut cette question de la défense
européenne continue d'être posée oui
vous avez raison de rappeler la
situation française et la situation
allemande qui sont différentes et celle
des autres pays européens mais encore
une fois imaginons que les États-Unis
qui ont commencé avec Obama à s'éloigner
de l'Europe c'est un fait et l'élection
de Trump a montré que le risque de de
d'abandonner cette relation singulière
avec l'Europe dans le cadre de
l'alliance Atlan
était pas une vue de l'esprit et donc ça
peut revenir et dans ce que vous dites
on a vraiment l'impression que
finalement c'est l'inverse du
documentaire c'est que c'est la France
qui ferait un peu cavalier seul ou qui
se tromperait un petit peu de direction
contrairement à à ses voisins européens
oui m oui je je pense réellement je
pense c'était très important de le dire
la majorité des Européens alors
qu'aujourd'hui le militaire est au
premier plan c'est vrai que pendant des
années ça jouait plus aucun rôle
personne ne pensait réellement qu' ou
menacé et là on découvre que la majorité
des pays misent sur l'OTAN et que c'est
la France qui crie tout le temps mais
euh euh
stratégie autonomie stratégique et moi
ce que je pense serait la bonne solution
c'est ne pas dire c'est l'un ou l'autre
c'est on peut faire les deux
c'est-à-dire là dans l'urgence je crois
effectivement on a tout entaré à miser
sur l'oton mais en même temps on doit
continuer avec avec nos projets
franco-allemand et là il faut une
véritable volonté politique sur laavion
du futur sur le char en commun et on on
voit alors que l'industrie militaire a
des grands succès commerciaux
actuellement on voit c'est plutôt un
problème industriel parce que ils sont
tous qui sont très très demandés donc
ils se disent oh ben finalement on peut
vendre tout seul d'ASS dit ça de son
côté et le fabricant de char allemand
dit aussi on est on est beaucoup mieux
quand on on n pas obligé de se mettre
d'accord dans dans ce contexte de je
crois que c'est exactement ça c'est la
réalité industrielle on est en
concurrence nos entreprises sont en
concurrence sur un marché qui est plutôt
en croissance ce qui manque c'est pas
que une Europe de la défense c'est une
Europe de des industries de l'armement
et c'est vrai que ça c'est quelque chose
dont on parle aussi depuis les années 90
quand j'étais étudiante on parlait déjà
de ça j'avais déjà des cours sur
l'industrie de l'armement européenne et
le fait qu'on y arrivait pas parce que
foncièrement on est en concurrence pour
des exportation pour nos économies parce
qu'on sait très bien que l'industrie
d'armement c'est fondamental aussi dans
notre balance commerciale et cetera donc
on est en concurrence c'est une réalité
et effectivement je crois que c'est très
très important on est tous d'accord
d'articuler défense européenne et
défense transatlantique et le geste qui
a été fait par Nicolas Sarkozi de de
réintégrer la France dans le
commandement militaire intégré de l'OTAN
avait en grande partie pour objectif le
fait aussi de rassurer nos partenaires
sur l'ancrage Atlantique de la France
puisque si ça marche pas c'est aussi
souvent parce que nous nous sommes
accusés de vouloir faire cavalier seul
sur le plan militaire et de finalement
détricoter la relation transatlantique
pour être positif il faut constater que
au moment de la de la l'agression russe
contre l'Ukraine la guerre en Ukraine
nous avons fait bloc justement on va ê
nous avons fait bloc entre Européens et
avec les États-Unis on on va être
positif sur sur la dernière partie de
cette émission vous avez raison
Jean-Marc herud parce que il y a aussi
he cette lueur d'espoir dans le dans le
film ce succès c'est cette dette commune
européenne qui a été adoptée après le
covid 750 milliards d'euros et dans ce
documentaire Bruno Lemire revient sur le
caractère historique de ce moment de cet
événement
regardez la dette en commun c'était un
tabou absolu la première fois que je
suis allé à Berlin comme ministre des
Finances en 2017 je me souviens d'une
discussion avec Wolfgang choybleu
ministre des Finances qui me dit écoute
tu parles de ce que tu veux à la presse
mais pas de dette en commun ça n'existe
pas et ça ne verra jamais le jour ça
n'est pas possible quand 4 ans plus tard
vous adoptez cette dette en commun vous
dites que voilà l'histoire est en
route Ron va pas revenir sur ce cet
événement en particulier mais peut-être
sur ce qu'il dit de cette relation
franco-allemande ça veut dire que
finalement quelque chose de très fort
est possible entre ces deux pays quand
ils se mettent d'accord nous avançons
malgré tout c'està-dire que il faut pas
être uniquement sur les différences qui
peuvent exister qui existent qui sont
réelles entre nos deux pays mais Infiné
nous sommes deux grandes démocraties les
deux pays les plus peuplés de l'Union
européenne les deux plus grandes
puissances économiques de l'Union
européenne et nous avons des intérêts
convergents qui sont des intérêts sur
les valeurs sur la démocratie des
intérêts tout simplement sur des
intérêts de puissance et donc même si
nous avons toute une série de d'accord
finalement ce qui l'emporte ce sont les
intérêts communs il y a un plus petit
dénominateur commun il y a des intérêts
communs et tous les pays européens
attendent aussi de nous de pouvoir nous
entendre parce que quand le couple
francoemand est regardé les trouvent un
terrain d'entente ce sont déjà un très
grand nombre des positions européennes
c'est-à-dire l'Europe du Nord l'Europe
du Sud l'Europe de l'Ouest l'Europe
centrale qui finalement peuvent trouver
que un certain nombre de positions se se
son son sont finalement convergente
parce que France et Allemagne n'ont pas
la même géographie en Europe et
défendent finalement des intérêts
européens qui sont naturellement un peu
différents c'est pourquoi quand ils se
mettent d'accord beaucoup d'autres pays
européens il trouvent leur compte et
donc c'est ce moteur là dont l'Europe a
absolument besoin les intérêts sont
supérieurs si vous voulez et que dire
des mots employés la semaine dernière
lorsque Olaf Scholz et Emmanuel Macron
se sont rencontrés à Hambourg 2 jours
ensemble pour justement essayie de
montrer une image de ce couple
franco-allemand qui continue de
fonctionner le président français a
parlé d'un devoir moral pour mieux se
comprendre de se remettre sur les rail y
compris sur l'épineux dossier de
l'énergie quant au chancelier allemand
il a déclaré qu'il y avait parfois des
perspectives différentes sur certaines
questions mais qu'il était possible de
développer un point de vue commun ils
essayent alors méthode Coué ou
réalité je pense nous avançons mais nous
avançons souvent sur des malentendus et
je pense l'exemple le le film le
documentaire a quand même un regard à
ses français le le
l'avance effectivement majeure de
l'endettement en commun c'était
considéré en Allemagne comme un cas
exceptionnel d'urgence et qu'on veut
surtout pas réééré alors que en en
France c'est lu comme l'entrée dans
quelque chose dans une nouvelle aventure
et c'est ça a toujours été comme ça
quand Conrad ad de Naar est venu la
première fois dans la maison de à Colomb
les deux églises à côté de de Charles de
Gaul Yvon de Gaul était tellement fâchée
qu'elle a pas voulu mettre la belle
assiette les belles vaisselles et ad
voyons qu' avait de la vaisselle
ordinaire a dit mais c'est formidable je
suis reçu en famille ils mettent même
plus et donc je pense souvent on avance
sur des malentendus et c'est ça la
beauté de notre relation oui ça peut
être inquiétant aussi Marion il faut
faire très attention aux assiettes ouais
Marion gaillard non mais je vous dites
que l'axe s'est déplacé à l'est c'est
vrai évidemment géographiquement c'est
vrai politiquement en grande partie mais
malgré tout je il n'y a pas
d'alternative c'est pour moi parce que
finalement oui bien sûr il y a le
triangle de vaimmar et on parle avec la
Pologne et on parle avec la République
tchèque ou d'autres pays bien entendu
mais finalement est-ce qu'il y a une
alternative à ce moteur franco-allemand
est-ce qu'on peut imaginer un moteur
germano-polonais est-ce qu'on peut
imaginer un moteur franco-italien on a
essayé miteran a essayé de regarder vers
les pays du Sud François Hollande aussi
quand il est arrivé de la même manière
que gerérard schreer à lornier sur Tony
Blair ça ne fonctionne pas il n'y a pas
d'alternative donc on peut tenter comme
je le dis toujours l'adultère mais on
revient dans le lit conjugal parce que
c'est là que l'intérêt est et c'est là
que ça fonctionne je crois que il faut
moi je sa bien qu'on parle de couple
mais il faut pas oublier ce que les
Allemands aiment aussi le moteur parce
que dans la période dans laquelle nous
sommes l'Europe a besoin qu'on relance
le moteur de l'avenir de la construction
européenne parce que à quoi vous pensez
quand actpp par rapport à la crise
économique le plan d'investissement avec
le financement par la par l'emprunt la
réaction collective contre l'Ukraine
c'est en réaction mais je crois que là
il faut qu'on passe un cap qu'on aille
plus loin le and vend le changement
d'air il faut le mettre en application
aussi au niveau de l'Europe l'Europe
c'est la plus grande puissance
économique et commerciale du monde ça
peut être aussi demain une garantie dans
un multilatéralisme qui est en crise
pour la sécurité mondiale et donc
l'Europe a une responsabilité de
civilisation et de démocratie à défendre
et donc ça ça passe par des décision on
ne pra pas par exemple l'élargissement
de l'Europe y compris au Balcans et à
l'Ukraine sans qu'on réforme nos
institutions pour que le projet
politique européen qui est une un acte
révolutionnaire d'avoir construit
l'Europe et qui est une garantie pour
les peuples pour leur sécurité et leur
avenir il faut que ça fonctionne et donc
on a besoin d'un moteur de temps en
temps ce moteur il est grippé en ce
moment il est un peu grippé mais ce
moteur franco-allemand il est dé
terminant pour tout le reste de l'Europe
il on décide pas à la place des autres
mais sans que ce moteur fonctionne bah
il y a quelque chose qui fonctionne pas
en europeope vous me donnez l'occasion
de faire un lien peut-être avec
l'actualité très forte en ce moment
l'actualité tragique au proche- Orient
et cette guerre en Israël est-ce que ce
couple franco-allemand et donc cette
Europe a un rôle à jouer face à cette
situation internationale et ce sera ma
dernière question Ron Lele il faut noter
que Angela Merkel l'avait notamment
signaler la la protection d'Israël est
pour les Allemands une raison de d'État
c'est ça ça c'est absolument fondamental
c'est exprimé avec constance et c'est à
nouveau exprimé ici avec beaucoup de
détermination par le chancelier Olaf
Scholz et effectivement là encore cette
capacité à parler à de voix voilà d'une
même voix dans ce soutien absolu à à à à
Israël qui est une démocratie une
véritable démocratie avec à
laacnaessette des voix dissonantes qui
sont capables de s'exprimer de façon
très forte et bien c'est une nécessité
non seulement évidemment pour le coup
franco-allemand mais bien au-delà c'est
une nécessité pour la voix de l'Europe
Mikel la vigel oui alors tout d'abord je
pense c'est un exemple clé où on voit
que l'histoire euh crée des positions
complètement différent c'est-à-dire
l'Allemagne a une dette ineffaçable
vis-à-vis d'Israël à cause de son
histoire à ce que l'Allemagne a fait aux
Juifs euh la France c'est différent je
trouve il y a plutôt un rapproche
notable qui vient de la
France de dans dans cette crise actuelle
où les positions sont très proche mais
pas suffisamment proche pour que le
président Macron et le chancelier schz
font un voyage ensemble en Israël au
regard de leur public et donc
malheureusement on a cette mise en scène
avec le chancellier Scholz qui va y
aller en même temps que le présid
président américain Biden et ça va
renforcer cette image que l'Allemagne en
quelque sorte se vit comme le partenaire
junior des États-Unis Marion gaillard en
quelques mots oui ben je vais pas
rajouter ça a été très bien dit
simplement le l'Union européenne a
toujours enfin a joué un rôle
relativement important au proche- Orient
depuis les années 80 avec déjà la
déclaration de Venise en 1980 sur à la
fois le droit pour Israël d'exister en
sécurité dans ses frontières dans son
état mais aussi le droit pour les
Palestiniens un état ça a été depuis les
années 80 la position de l'Europe de la
communauté puis de l'Union européenne on
a été un peu effacé des accords d'Oslo
qui ont été signés sur la pelouse de la
Maison Blanche mais en revanche après
l'union européenne a été extrêmement
présente sur le terrain par des fonds
pour financer des hôpitaux des des
écoles une administration et cetera donc
on est là sur le terrain on a parfois du
mal à en tirer les dividendes politiques
parce que effectivement c'est plutôt les
États-Unis qui qui sont au centre des
négociation quand il y en a et nous on
est plutôt sur le terrain à essayer
d'aider notamment les Palestiniens pour
le coup parce que c'est un un un
territoire beaucoup moins développé
évidemment qu'Israël oui oui et puis là
il faut vraiment se parler parce que ce
que nous ce qui se passe au Proche
Orient est terrible vous avez eu les
mots qui convenaient pour qualifier ce
que était fait par le Hamas on va dire
un grand pogrom euh comme on a jamais
connu depuis la Seconde Guerre mondiale
donc avec des des des actes atroces et
donc la solidarité avec Israël et ça
pour assurer garantir sa sécurité elle
est totale elle est entière et de ce
point de vue nous partageons le point de
vue allemand mais en même temps on voit
bien que nous sommes dans une dans un
face à un grand risque d'engrenage euh
de de drame humanitaire à Gaza
d'embrasement en sisjordanie
peut-être que finalement l'Iran qui
s'introduirait dans ce dans ce conflit
avec en en incitant le Hezbollah à
attaquer Israël au Sud Liban donc donc
le rôle de l' donc l'Europe l'Europe
c'est à la fois de de d'être très clair
pour aider Israël a assuré sa sa
sécurité d'avoir aucune ambiguïé sur ce
plan puis en même temps d'être un acteur
de la paix hein et c'est vrai que le
peuple palestinien a espéré pendant
longtemps que certains accords notamment
les accords d'Oslo soient mis en œuvre
ils ne l'ont jamais été et on a vu au
contraire la colonisation en sjordanie
se développer avec tout ce que ça
comporte comme violence donc il y aura
des choses chose à dire sans doute dans
les prochains mois et et ces choses
c'est d'abord le peuple israélien qui
les dira en enquêtant sur l'action du
Premier ministre netaniahou de ses
alliances avec l'extrême droite qui ont
peut-être d'ailleurs mis en péril la
sécurité d'Israël donc on est face à à
de grands défis et c'est vrai qu'on a
pas fini de de se mobiliser et d'en
parler ensemble français et allemand
avec chacun notre sensibilité notre
expérience notre histoire je crois que
c'est nécessaire pour tous et toutes et
je pense que le moteur franco-allemand
le couple franco allemand a un bel
avenir devant lui et on s'arrêtera sur
ces paroles optimistes merci merci à
tous les quatre d'avoir participé à cet
échange merci à vous de nous avoir suivi
comme chaque semaine à très bientôt sur
public CNA
[Musique]
merci